because the biographies of the other
panelists are all listed on the
registration
website
you have access to their distinguished
achievements so i'm going to introduce
them in the briefest possible way
um and have them take seven minutes uh
to make an introductory statement after
which we will have a discussion and
hopefully allow questions from the floor
uh as well um
first uh
is mathida
who is a
surgeon and novelist
and
a
large figure in the international pen
movement
and
[Music]
very well known as an activist
and so let me turn over the floor to her
for seven minutes
thank you everybody and i think it's
very hard to cover
what's happening right now in my country
in seven minutes but i try my best and
first of all i would like to focus on
the governance issue the
after the coup the military
it cannot show its uh
qualify enough to govern the country
especially in mcqueen divisions again
division
and uh chin states of course and then
the kachin states and the yangon it's
not as the whole region but especially
in the city area
but at the same time
they are trying to control
through the village level administrators
on the ground for the majority of the
country in that case the from the
revolution side people defense forces
are trying to focus on these
uh
local administrator as they are
precursors to
send all the informations to the uh
the soldiers or the the military age a
whom to arrest
whom to kill etc that's why uh the the
current situation about the governance
issue is pretty much in
uh question mark
and the pdf focusing on killing this
kind of the
low-call village level administrators
naming them as the land the informer
so in terms of the legislature the
military
you know since the coup they don't care
about
the
either uh
initiation or the amendment of the any
law apart from the cyber security law
in that case you know right now the
people defense forces and the revolution
people focusing on
uh destroying the mighty tower
you know from from the very beginning
since the military do the internet
shutdown deliberately
in the whole country but right now
focusing on this hard to govern area
uh they do the international down for
example like in the ki area of pakan and
right now in sakai and the part of the
chain state
but at the same time the pdf focusing on
the mitel tower
and then the miter miter owned by the
military party owned by vietnamese
business
company then the writer started saying
about uh internet shutdown will
smartly interfere for the sake of the
information etc even though
the military introduced the cyber
security law and all the
kind of the
uh whitelist introduction
and etc as soon as it took the power you
know but nug has been doing quite a lot
of the
[Music]
law and force uh not not law amendment
or the initiation then recently the
uh the nug studied the income tax
law the amendment of the income tax law
in order to have more donation
indirect donations
and from the business people rich
business people and italy uh
citizens they normally don't take but in
the revolutions through
the protest not through the
the
any other ways but they they have the
money they can indirectly support its uh
the revolution so
this is also very uh pretty much the
ground situation on the legislature and
the
uh
in terms of rule of law
the killing
and arbitrary arrest looting
asking for the ransoms for the
the arrested people or the dead bodies
the arsons on the burning the whole
village and bombing this is going on
from the military side and
they sometimes accuse the people defense
forces as the
culprit was there even though they
already have their own
version of the civilian
uh violence attackers under the name of
you saw tea something like that
but the the way they look at the rule of
law issue is for example like recently
uh
a lady that the daughter of the high
rank military officer has been shooted
at very late night when she was driving
back from somewhere
and the security forces stopped her and
she didn't stop and she kept driving and
she was shooting to death
and in that case the military supporters
started staying there oh you see
uh our military is good enough they
don't care whoever uh betrayed the law
they are taking action they never ever
think this should not be done you know
the the killing to those
uh people without knowing them
it's arbitrary killing but the way of
the
concept of the military supporter on
rule of law is like something like that
but at the same time i we have so much
concern about
the
for longer term problems if
everybody
just thinking of the armed revolution is
the solution but recently i was so happy
to learn the cdm the civil disobedience
police
they started
making an announcement saying that they
backed the patents from the people
for
the
institutional
uh
wrongdoing during the saffron revolution
in 2007 even though they are not the
real corporate only a commitment a
committer of this crime they feed the
institution has a responsibility and
they try to back the burden from the
people so it's
the way the
the revolutions group uh thinking on the
issue of rule of law is quite promising
to me in that case and
yes the last thing is all about the
resilience and the resistance it's not
just from the people and we learning
more and more
uh people the soldiers are defecting and
the the way the
revolution
be people resistance is uh more
like uh
just trying to stop the military
dictatorship not focusing on
the
uh
violence for the longer run so that that
will cover thank you thank you
thank you
the next uh speaker
is
a professor in political science at
carleton uh college he was a student
leader in 1988 uh
uprising
as a phd from indiana
or a book on international treaties
concerning the mekong and the rhine and
is a founder of the mutual aid myanmar
that is has gathered lots of
contributions uh to help
striking public sector workers uh koton
please
thank you very much jen and thank you
for to all of you who are listening to
this panel and i will offer two broad
historical related all
frameworks uh two broad frameworks
related to all rooted in burmese history
and then one philosophical reflection on
the current crisis
so i'll start with the first one the
first one is related to china and brahma
relation and that has to go back to the
end of four sino-burmese war
uh at the end of 19 and 1769.
so um one uh emperor of qin dynasty chin
long
decided uh to end the the fourth wall
attempting to annex burma he issue a
proclamation to his military leaders
in that military uh leaders uh
programmation this is what uh chilean
said uh quote uh beginning the quote
when you send the army
for an attack there should be a fewer
soldiers lightly armed
they should
take advantage of the enemy's lack of
readiness to just destroy their crops
and kill a few and take a few prisoners
the purpose is no more than to disturb
them but not really a world or big scale
so that edit which uh the the chin alone
issue
stay played today in terms of creating
uh buffer zones on the thai burma i'm
sorry myanmar and china border war
ethnic groups tnla and
aaa which was born in kia area all play
in that game of
the end of the war but what
chandler wanted was the permanent war in
burma where no peace can be settled and
so today's ethnic
uh uh conflict and then the march to the
federal open inclusive framework is a
struggle here china's post on burma uh
wa uh tnla in all other ethnic groups
that has not been
explicitly saying that we support nug so
nug uh has been supported by people and
so on so that framework is a pretty
important here because unlimited war
endless war is what china wanted that is
happening in myanmar and it is happening
now
uh so second um i think that he did was
on february 6
1770 he issued
economic amber gold against burmese
king
that so this might be perhaps the first
economic sanction imposed by a country
against another country in the world
history
it is certainly the first economic
sanction
issue in asia asian continent so in that
economic session his addict said i'm
going to quote him again
as for the matter of trade the myanmar
bandits are eager to exchange with china
this is shown clearly in several letters
they sent fortunately i have foreseen
this and i ordered repeatedly that they
could only ask for it after they submit
to us
in short no trade with china will be
allowed before the arrival of their
surrender letter this method is the best
way to control the foreign barbarians so
that was his addict on issue on february
6
1770 against burma and so that trade
practice is still
useful today to understand the
investment of chinese investment in
burma the economic influence that china
is exercising in maneuvering this crisis
in myanmar in fact to sensible support
the first goal that they have which is
just basically burma should never get
rich never have peace and that is
chinese foreign policy rooted in 1770
and it is continuing today and so those
two frameworks are very important for us
to understand why the coup why may
online and military leaders are really
totally relying on china at the unsc and
other area of international affairs so
that's the first one second one i want
to talk about is the history of state
building in burma the history of state
building in burma need to be understood
to understand why the struggle for
federalism inclusive open federalism is
so difficult
um the first uh
the the unifier of burma is up as we
know anoreka and then the bayen noun and
then the the
the the the olympia and these three
kings uh statues are erected in nebido
and now on the china burma border city
is beginning to be built to have that
three statue of these kings what they
did and what they created as a unifying
burma was a burman ethnocentric state
legitimized by buddhist dog training
which are supported by the sangha which
is more of a materialist sangha than the
spiritual and philosophical and more
actually what buddha really taught to
understand the world so that materialist
buddhism buddhists or materialist
buddhists are good examples uh uh
current theorem in 969 nationalist
buddhist monks all of them play in
legitimizing the state that may outline
the fourth uh uh group uh which is
because
the the the the the three berman empire
have failed to base uh build the berman
state now main online and military
leaders attempting to build that state
with 2008 constitution and that was
their document to begin unifying them
burman state and that state
failed and by design because the cdn
participant protesters and ea ohs do not
want that kind of state survive or tribe
in burma they want that state to fail so
the state failure in burma is it by
design and society is resilient and
robust against that state and that is
really good news for open and inclusive
federalism in the into the future uh we
can get that into detail in our point
and the final point that i wanted to
offer is the
uh my reflection on the current violence
that the violence that matthias have
already spoken about generally and
everywhere happening i mean you can
imagine seven years old daughters uh
being shot at on the left of the father
in mandalay you can imagine a poet
killed and opened his chest and taking
out organs uh from him that would be the
poet uh kathy from mongol and and the
crimes against humanity and the scale of
violence and if you will
dirty creativity of the violence by the
myanmar military is stunning we are the
world is experiencing and seeing it
every day happening unpacked in burma so
the question for political scientists
especially and maybe international
lawyers especially is is there
a proper violence and is there a proper
role of violence in politics uh
establishment and i think uh for us
international relations scholars uh just
for theory rooted in hindu tradition
philosophy offer
some kind of root to actually imagine
that there might be proper violence and
there might be legitimate violence and
there might be just war that we could uh
consider in especially if we are or the
the world is moving toward a more uh uh
inclusive open liberal framework of
democratic world
against chinese and russian order of
centralized order so if we want to
really open up to the protect or
somewhat imagine the agency and freedom
of
individuals around the world in the
world order that is coming into the
future we might have to rethink about
the way in which uh the utopian peace is
imagined so that's all i have to offer
uh thanks corton uh the next keeper
speaker is david thomp
he's a phd candidate
in history and theological studies at
the ashbury theological seminar in
kentucky uh and by going to his website
this morning i realized that he's the
author of uh dozens of articles uh on
ethnic conflict on a
religion
on buddhist nationalism and so on
some of which i put under my belt but
it's quite an impressive
reading list and i
admire what he's had to say in several
panels that we've jointly participated
in david you have seven minutes
uh thank you so much for your kind
introduction sir professor james scott
and uh it's very good to see you again
after
sharing of penny at yonsei university in
south korea
um
i will be speaking from the perspective
of the ethnic and religious minority so
speaking from that it's uh
it's not possible to ignore buddhist
nationalism and all this the ethnic
identity or maybe even ideology conflict
so i just want to focus on that
uh topic today
so um i would like to briefly touch on
the uh uh politics of religions and the
origins and movement of buddhist
nationalism in our country
buddhist nationalism is nothing new in
myanmar it's it has been rooted in the
british colonial period in in the 19th
century
but the way that buddhist nazism emerge
is different from each department or
each movement
uh in a british colonial period it
emerged as the anti-western influence i
would like to prefer the word
anti-western influence instead of
anti-foreign influence if we put it
anti-foreign influence we can say that
well now the military government is
related to uh china and russia and all
this like that so
i prefer the word buddhism emerge in the
british colon period as the anti-western
influence so it was during that time
that uh the burma independence army
which this the current music government
always say that that is the root of
their movement it was formed to fight
against the british colon period and
they always claim that that is how they
came to our gain independence uh from uh
british so let's move to the second
movement which is slightly from the
first movement so in the uh in the
post-colonial period or what i'll call
it post-independent period the buddhist
nations in in myanmar emerged as the
anti-bummer or maybe the
anti-non-buddhist
movement right so uh for example uh unu
uh make our famous uh slogan what he
called
father dada so if you are not a buddhist
in myanmar you will face some
discriminations
so uh uh
there are at least three main
characteristics of that buddhist
nationalism first political domination
is very obvious and the second is that
the ethnic cultural asset simulations so
the ethnic minority cultures has been
assimilated to the the dominant buddhist
cultures and then the third is the
religious discrimination so if you are
not a buddhist you will face some
discriminations in many ways uh in
myanmar and so what i would like to put
here is that there is a uh
the concept flag and fake right so
this the buddhist
led military government
imagined the politics in myanmar in
their buddhist way of thinking so that
is what happened so especially in this
post-independent uh period what i would
call it make buddhism great again which
has been very uh
very obvious in myanmar and then of
course some of these uh the military
garment leaders are influenced by donald
trump's logan definitely make uh
uh make america great again right so
they also use make buddhism great again
because they feel that buddhism was
declined during the british colonial
period so that's how they feel
so now let's move to the third movement
what i would call it old buddhist
nationalism in the new coup
in this movement it's slightly different
from the previous two movement in this
movement it's not quite it's not just
the uh ethnic identity conflict but also
the ideology conflict so that means the
conflict is not just between the
majority burma buddhist
and ethnic minority group
but among the buddhists also have some
conflict right so that is something
important to remember here so buddhism
against buddhism that is obvious and
then military dictatorship against
democracy movement as well as the bummer
against obama so that means the conflict
becomes bigger than
the the second one and the third uh the
the little one
uh so let me uh touch on these
opportunities and challenges
so
the rise of this the new coup create the
opportunity of inter religious and
ethnic solidarity among
these uh
protesters
so it
comes to the
crisis of rohingya but in this current
movement people from different religious
and different ethnic groups come
together and share their inter-related
solidarity or maybe a unity of course
the question is how
deep that unity is but at least we can
see that this the cool creek the
opportunity of inter-religious and
inter-ethnic solidarity for the
democracy movement especially that
movement is uh led by the uh generation
c or maybe the young generation you can
see in this picture
uh one on the left is a sazino from
kachin and the right one uh is uh
ethnically shiny uh eating zamon and so
they just try to uh
bridge their religious and uh ethnic
device to confront the military coup as
their common enemy this is something
important to remember in this korean
movement
so here is my question eight months into
the coup what is the state of democracy
movement uh
uh earlier madita and uh tom yin has
covered a lot of things and let me
briefly touch on that from the uh
perspective of the ethnic minority issue
so in my view in these eight months of
the coup there are two strategies that
the people are using today in myanmar
uh first is a non-violence in the
beginning they protest on the street in
a non-violent wage
but the military government use a
violent crackdown on the on the peaceful
protesters
and then maybe sometimes in march
they start
thinking about how they should uh uh
themselves uh self-defense
so in that case
uh they use a violent wage and and
especially in mind where i'm from uh
originally uh they formed this up pdf
people defense force which
has been chained to a cdf later on uh to
uh to make their chain this resistant
movement unique so that is something
that we can see so in this second
strategy we can also see that the way
the current movement is also trying to
go beyond sensoji method of non-violence
and
we we don't know whether onsen studio
might agree with that or not that is we
don't know but what we can say here is
that the current movement is trying to
trying to go beyond sansuji method of
non-violence
you have to stop soon david yes okay so
here uh
let me go here uh to the uh
to the third point my question is do the
ethnic
minorities and ethnic majorities share
the same visions i think the answer is
yes but we still can further argue that
the ethnic majority have a vision of
freedom from the coup
but the ethnic minority have a double
visions not
freedom not only from the crew but also
from the buddhist nationalism that is
something significant
and let me move to the last point does
nyama have the future of democracy if no
why and if yes how
that could be uh i mean we might have
different obedience but in my view yes
the answer is yes but we need two
movements not only internal movement in
myanmar but also the external movement
and international communities
cooperation with the international
movement
in that case i will urge the
international community to recognize ngg
and second i will urge the international
community to advocate for freedom of
myanmar people in many ways and third to
financially support the cdm strikers and
idp people and i believe that the uh the
next speaker uh u.s ambassador scott
martin will talk a little bit more about
this issue thank you
thank you david
um next let me recognize scott martial
uh a career foreign service officer who
uh has spent most of his career uh in
southeast asia was ambassador to
indonesia ambassador to burma and
ambassador to asean scott
you have seven minutes
thanks very much um and uh thanks for
letting me join this panel um as sort of
the outsider among the four speakers
since uh the other three obviously are
from myanmar and i'm very clearly not
but have had the pleasure of spending
some time there um
i'd like to friend
my comments
a little bit in in a big picture uh sort
of policy way um
the way i look at this situation
the
myanmar military the top medal as we
know around the country
from 1962 to 2010 2010-11 before it
started
loosening up allowing reforms
and and in that roughly 50-year period
they ran the country about as badly as
one can run a country uh in every
respect obviously
there's rightly been a huge amount of
focus on the conflict
and human rights violations and lack of
freedom and democracy
but they also managed to drive the
economy into the ground while destroying
or obviously destroying the health
system the education system and actually
exacerbating the very ethnic conflicts
which david mentioned
that their rule was supposed to resolve
so you have that history and then you
had the period of roughly a decade
when the reforms began from when the
reforms began in 2011-12
until the coup this year and in that
period
you had a lot of reform
you had significant increases in freedom
you had
a near consensus on the need to move
toward
federal democracy
um in the period i was there 2016 to
2020
a lot of us focused and a lot of the
media attention focused on the areas of
continuing disagreement and problem the
rohingya crisis
the continuing conflict and the lack of
movement on the peace process uh
continuing problems with lack of full
freedoms and and human rights uh the
military's continuing human rights
violations and so on
but when i look back at it now all of
those things were very real and there's
very serious challenges that the country
uh
still you know was confronting and still
has to confront
but in my view there was near consensus
in the country on one thing
that the country had an opportunity to
move forward
and it was moving forward in fits and
starts
and
everybody just about everybody
was adamant that the one thing that they
did not want to see was a return to the
battle days of military rule
and so the coup
on february 1st in addition to being
completely unjustified illegitimate
you name it um it
it it basically met instant opposition
from almost the entire country
um because of course people didn't want
to have their freedoms taken away and
their democracy
uh flawed as it might have been taken
away but also i think because people saw
their hope and their opportunity for a
better future being taken away
and so i think this helps explain
the
incredibly widespread uh resistance
peaceful and otherwise
to a return to military rule this is not
you know
some opposition
movements this is really the country of
myanmar
ethnic obama and ethnic minorities
pretty much together
united and what's in effect a national
resistance against a military rule that
is
i view is largely the equivalent of
occupying force in the sense that they
have no legitimacy no popular support
no real
uh interest
in helping people live better lives i
mean it's striking the talmudia doesn't
really care how much people suffer
it's almost unimaginable i mean they not
only impose their own suffering
but weaponize covid and take other
measures that make it clear they don't
they don't give a damn about the people
at all
it's all about power for them
so
going forward
um i i don't see
the resistance to the coup waning
um if anything it will increase both
again peaceful means and and
non-peaceful means um the topman given
its history is unlikely to
uh you know say okay well we'll just
give up
so sadly i think that means for some
time we're gonna see more
suffering uh more violence and it and
it's it is really important i think
people are aware it is really important
to remember and to think every day about
the incredible amount of human suffering
that's going on as a result of this coup
uh throughout the country um the
violence for sure
people suffering from covid and not
being able to get a
adequate uh medical
help
people being displaced
people losing their jobs going hungry uh
i mean across the board it's a it's a
just a horrific humanitarian situation
and um
i think it's important that the world
stay very focused on that and remember
this is not just a political problem
it's a it's a problem of of human it's a
humanitarian crisis and a problem of
human suffering
um going forward looking for a little
bit
further there's been this sort of
discussion or debate about you know
whether dialogue is needed whether
dialogue is appropriate to try to
resolve this problem and it's it's
really tricky i think it's really
important to be careful how we talk
about this
um because neither side is unlikely to
just give up or surrender
at some point uh probably there will be
a need for some kind of discussions to
hopefully find a way out of this but i
think what's key is that the circ the
conditions now are not right for that
the hunt has shown no interest in
discussions i mean they've completely
ignored and blown off asean efforts to
to mediate
they've shown no interest in this at all
and my sense is that a lot of the people
a lot of myanmar people are not
interested in discussions at this point
now so i think the the
hope for me for the future
my belief is that
what's needed is for more pressure on
the junta domestic pressure and
international pressure
because i don't believe they're going to
be able to restore stability and be able
to govern the country okay
and i think that what's needed is
intensive pressure over a long period of
time
so that more and more military officers
understand that they have no hope of
winning and at that point they may be
able to be willing to look for a way out
and make concessions which then could
lead to the beginning of dialogue i'll
stop there
thank you scott um i wanted to add a
couple of things just into the mix for
the subsequent discussion um the thing
that does strike me is that the burma
are now
suffering a form of
direct violence and depression
that the ethnic minorities have been
suffering from uh since 1962 uh and it's
now come if you like to the burmese
heartland and i as a political scientist
i don't know actually of another regime
another military
that is so universally
despised that is this is not a rebellion
by students and cosmopolitan elites in
the cities this is a rebellion by the
entire population uh in villages uh um
rural villages
uh and
ethnic minority areas it is
such a completely predatory regime that
has no popular base and no popular
support that's an extraordinary
situation that um in the long run
uh
this is a regime that governs by
sheer repression violence and terror
and
the
interesting thing to me is that
the time at all
because it has its own education system
its own
[Music]
supply chain it has its own health care
system it has its own
pensions it insists that people stay on
the barracks it is probably the most
insulated
uh military of the the world has seen
there may be a couple of other examples
a little like it but what's
extraordinary is that you could say that
the madonna does not really live in
burma uh that is to say they are so
insulated so the the horrific question
is that
that insulation
insulates it to some considerable degree
how much i don't know
from
internal defections from a split in the
officer core and so on it looks although
there are defections um there's no
evidence that you're going to have a
split in the military which
would lead to a situation uh i think of
perhaps uh more radical change um so i
just wanted to put that on the table i
wanted to open it both for um
let's
let's have the participants
um
uh chime in with their questions if your
question
is it would be good if your question
were directed um
to one or another of the panelists uh
because then we would save a good deal
of time rather than having four people
answered
uh so i'll leave it to chris or to eric
to recognize
uh
members of the audience um
uh who have questions
can we have that again there's a
question in the chat yeah i see it um
should i address that question
please um this is the question is um how
do you think the role of asean leaders
in coping helping the current situation
in myanmar um
but i think you you have in within asean
uh some governments that seem extremely
concerned about the situation and have
been quite outspoken and then you have
others
um who have been less so um so asean
seems divided
i think you saw the early effort back in
april
to to
have this emergency meeting
and which they came up with five points
supposedly of agreement although the
junta immediately sort of rejected them
um
within a day or two i believe
of the agreement and since then i think
asean struggled to find a way forward um
you know this is really harmful for
asean this makes in addition to the
suffering of the myanmar people um
myanmar once again has returned to being
a a really black mark for asean as one
of its members is behaving in this in
this horrific you know it's the military
at least behaving in this horrific
fashion and i think i think asean is
really struggling
uh with how to deal with it they don't
have really measures of you know
coercive measures to employ
to pressure uh myanmar that much their
approach is normally one to try to use
the sort of asean family relationship uh
to try to win trust and and sort of have
quiet talks and try to nudge
um but um
you know i don't know that anyone's ever
succeeded in quietly nudging this
military the top mcdonald uh they're not
knowledgeable if if that's a if that's a
word um so i i do think um it's been a
little bit disappointing uh but i think
it's important that the asean members
keep keep pushing because their own
organization is being undermined by what
happens as well as the stability of the
region is being undermined
by the junta and this coup so i i hope
the asean leaders will keep looking for
ways to
push the generals to rethink this
next question
um we have a question from newton um and
then after that there's a question in
the chat there's actually two questions
in the chat but they turn out to be the
same person um one came via email and
one into the chat so i say we take the
question from you john first and then
the question from the chat
thank you everyone thank you all for
your comments um i was gonna type the
question in the chat box but i will um
state it here my question is directed to
dr matthida
and it has to do with why does the
military or the regime the legislature
particulars you've described
bother with law at all like when
killings can be arbitrary and the regime
is governed by as
uh professor scott described you know
sheer repression violence and terror why
why why bother with law at all
thank you so much
well you know the
the
concept behind forming or recruiting the
soldiers into the myanmar terminal
itself has so many problems
already you know the incentives to
become the
military officer or the soldier is not
to protect the people
that's very clear it's just to make them
having a privileged positions among the
others especially above citizens so the
concept of the terminal and the soldiers
and military officers is they are
justified
people
to govern or to bully the citizens
that's that's made
more
uh clear after the coup and after the
because of the
economic sanctions and other
disobedience from the citizens military
itself have not much uh income
to
uh give some enough supports to its uh
subordinates so especially on the ground
the soldiers uh
hunger
and
for that reasons the and then the rule
of not never being
the issue for the military leaders
that's why they just let them do
whatever the arbitrary uh
uh
so much inhumane
things to do and then i think the
another thing is since
the february there was no single day
a to get rest for the soldiers and the
army met because of the
either the peaceful
protest or the um struggle is going on
everywhere all over the country this was
the
very hard for them for the
non-stop action for more than seven
eight months
in that case they
uh just
in
uh
kind of the
deep bitterness and angers and they
cannot think of the better solutions
rather than making
as much as forces onto the citizens to
get cooling down or to get
afraid of doing anymore something like
that so that one case and another case
is they are somehow addicted to either
alcohol or the drugs the the
method to me by themselves the military
soldiers and the military officers
that's why their inhumane activities is
more or less related that's why we have
been noticing a lot of the fighting
among each other after uh too much
drinking alcohol
the soldiers killed its its uh
military officer that's going on so i
think the and then there it there will
be the key
ongoing the impunity issue
the hiring military officer they never
ever take any action against their
subordinates whatsoever whatever they do
they do that's why the ransom cases is
almost like not just betraying the
citizens but also betraying itself the
dumber itself they never let the
military officer know but on the ground
they're trying to get as much as
possible from the families members of
the arrested uh revolutionists you know
that's how they get earned money during
this kind of the desperate period this
is the period of despair for them to you
know they cannot get dressed they need
to do something else they are
also they need to feed for their family
members and whereas they can get money
you know their salary is not
pretty much granted by the military
regime too so
it is like these vicious cycles that's
i guess i just wanted to
add to that
[Music]
the pattern of
absolute predatory robbery ransom and so
on much of which has nothing to do with
uh it's just the military turned loose
to make money by
uh kidnapping people and holding their
families and so on i thought the
question however
is worth pondering and i don't have
quite the answer to it and that's the
question of why did they bother
with this patina
with this fog
of legality the fact is that people were
charged under section 505
so what's interesting to me is that they
do whatever they want to do
but they require and it shows us the
legitimacy
of the rule of law at some level they
have to have this curtain in which it
appears that there's a section of the
legal code that they are using they have
lawyers they have judges they have
the whole point of a successful
dictatorship today
uh is to have the institutional facade
of a democracy including elections
judges uh uh and legal codes uh and to
under that cover do whatever you want
but it shows us
actually that behind all of this
there's a tremendous legitimacy of the
rule of law
and of democratic governance
because they have to fake it
constantly
um yes next uh
question the one was uh uh in the chat i
gather eric
again
jim thank you uh there's there's a
series of questions
that kind of congeal around the
u.s state department's position
on violence in myanmar i'd like to
broaden that question just a little bit
so that it's not only directed to the
ambassador but it's clearly on people's
mind
um
had also mentioned the idea of is there
a case of just war right or just
violence
and so
obviously the questions would like to
hear what ambassador scott martial has
to say about u.s position on that um
which is maybe a tall task to announce
in a panel like this but i do think the
topic of
violence when it's just or not
deserves some attention by the panel so
if all of you can reflect on that
briefly i think that would be great
scott
um thanks um
i'll try to address it on
what's that was a bit of a caveat first
i i want to stress its former ambassador
um so i am not the ambassador to to
myanmar um and uh what i'm gonna say is
is absolutely my personal views it does
not represent the views
necessarily represent the views of the
u.s government or the state department
i think
first
it would be very difficult for the us
government and many other governments to
come out and say we support violence
it's just you know i the way i look at
this is that um
the the military created this situation
with the coup
and then when peaceful tried people
tried the peaceful
uh approach of you know civil
disobedience and peaceful protest and so
on uh the military respond responded
with horrific violence as we know
um so
you know one can argue that people
weren't really left with the option of
either dialogue or peaceful protest and
so it's it's unbelievable that some
people have have taken
uh taken other measures i think it's
again it's it's quite
difficult for uh
the us government or other governments i
think to come out and say we support
violence but i think if you looked at
the totality of statements from the u.s
government and the state department it's
very clear that they place
responsibility for what's happened on
the military junta and are very much in
support of uh of the people and of uh
efforts to restore i wouldn't even say
restore efforts to move the country back
onto
a democratic path with a government that
respects people and and human rights
anyone else on the panel
well i just want to uh add one point
that's why i think from the very
beginning the people of myanmar
requesting for having the r2b the
responsibility to protect in that sense
and still
i have so much concern about the
transition of justice for the longer run
for that reasons we seriously do have a
presence of the
kind of the third party security forces
on the ground otherwise there will be
an unstoppable
uh revenge on conflict going on and that
will be the end of our country for that
reason i think the trust between the
current military and trust uh current
military and the people of myanmar has
already been finished it cannot be built
again it's ever finished already that's
why i we seriously do need the
uh third party security forces
to
uh re-establish the rule of law inside
the country without that i think that's
why we don't want any of the governments
in the world to support the violence
inside we want the international
community to help our safe member in
terms of uh making
the
physical
and literal uh
protection for the sake of the people
the lives of the people the properties
of the
people either uh uh either way it it it
might be through the un platform or
anyway but uh to be friends because of
this failure a lot of our people have
lost their trust in any institutions
including asean and u.n this is the very
dangerous for the longer runs
i i wanted to add
to that that
actual intervention
by un or foreign powers is off the table
um i think we should start with that
assumption however there are lots of
things that the international community
uh can do
uh one of them is to put even more
pressure on the non-partisan delivery of
humanitarian aid
in burma
to
communities that is not just distributed
by the tatmadol another thing they can
do is to persuade the thai military to
give the people who are fleeing to
uh chiang mai and messiah uh uh
temporary correct uh protected status uh
as uh political refugees uh so that they
are not subject to arrest by the thai
military and being thrown back uh into
myanmar uh and presumably that same
thing goes for
the 11 500 people who were in mizoram uh
and who fled to the uh to the west uh
many of the chin as david knows uh so it
seems to me that that uh short of
intervention which will never happen
um uh forcible intervention there are a
lot of things that the international
community can do that have not yet been
accomplished
if i can add to uh the conversation
there are two questions that
international community can
begin to ponder on one
is considering the type and amount of
violence that military is injecting on
the public and we are daily reading
facebook feed twitters and all that
the question for international community
within the u.n charter
chapter one six and seven to consider is
is the myanmar military considering that
it lost the trust and the legitimacy of
all types in within myanmar is myanmar
military
becoming the world's largest terrorist
organization
winning a threat to not just the
domestic people meaning citizens of
myanmar but also the threat to the
integrity of united nation charter that
enshrined the state sovereignty and is
myanmar military uh delivering all
insulting stakes over in myanmar and
giving to another party which would be
to china that myanmar military might be
actually now
in fact if you listen to the uh several
interaction between peace minister aomin
under the fensing administration with
the down villagers almin himself
admitted that myanmar could not override
whatever china's want to do in myanmar
meaning that they have to listen to
china so the question is that's
integrity of the u.n charter integrity
of the state sovereignty of myanmar is
under threat that question needs to be i
think at the u.n security council level
consider
second question is in terms of the
intervention and also type of
intervention the myanma
the indonesian community might consider
i think we might really be critically uh
now forced to in the case of myanmar or
the case of the way of being violence in
myanmar by the military is that
is there a type of uh war that is just
in in terms of guiding the type of
intervention that need to be done to
protect
the the the foundation of the the world
the community which is the individual
agency and freedom if individual agency
and freedom become a dire threat uh
and if our freedom if i'm pointed a gun
uh my on my forehead i should have a
just response to that person who is
going to kill me uh who is going to turn
my light so with that question i think
the the the extrapolating the just worth
theory and understanding september seven
uh defensive wall that nug uh sort of
prepare not declare i would say it's
just preparation uh you they use the
emergency situation just for the people
to prepare for it i think that kind of
questions are becoming uh more relevant
for the future diplomacy and the the
indonesian
order because united states may not
declare that we support the violence but
united states had invaded so many
countries and changed
and tragedy the history of the country
if you think about it if you think about
these within the just war theory that
obama illegally spoke at his nobel peace
prize i think these are kind of
questions we need to really consider for
international diplomats and scholars if
we don't what we are doing is we're
basically uh listening or watching that
pendulum swinging between nazi type of
regime to the democratic urban type and
that would be the world history for uh
maybe five millennia or eight millennia
to come and that is a shame if we are
learning from books and thinking about
these problems and the nation the nature
of this violence that we cannot accept
even to see on the screen that is what
at stake for a lot of uh educational
institutions and practitioners
that's where i would at two
but david i know you've been having
internet troubles can you hear now and
would did you want to add to this
conversation before we move on
can you hear me now
yes
oh so sorry uh my internet is not stable
here because in my ear it's raining so i
miss many parts of the conversation i
don't know where i should start um
just let me briefly add to the
conversation about the violence and
non-violence um
i mean
some international community might think
that the way uh democracy movement in
myanmar is only violent
and violence they feel that these two
ways could be more effective to
determine but
that could be true but on the other hand
what we have to think is that the the
suffering of the the
um uh the civilians uh people those who
do not join in this armed group like for
example now in minded uh in my hometown
and then tantlan uh uh i mean because of
this uh violent fight many civilians
left their hometown like for example
tanjung in chin state only 28 people
stayed
in their town and the rest of the people
they just flare to jungles and some are
miurums and so what i can say here is
that i mean violence could be a good way
to defeat this dictatorship but we also
need to consider the suffering of those
uh
innocent people uh so in that case i
really don't know how the international
community could do some help more
effectively that might be my uh my
addition
as uh
let me just uh turn things over as
moderator to eric since uh as eric knows
i have to leave promptly at uh
at one uh so
thank you all for coming uh and i turn
the moderator uh roll over to eric thank
you
thanks jim
um
so
david's point there brings us to a nice
transition to some of the questions in
here about non-violent responses um
or other diplomatic responses there was
a question from paul sarno about uh
sanctions towards the moge which i
assume is a gas and electric or a
ministry um
and there's also one that follows
immediately from that from motuzar about
the asean dialogues um in in
the asean summits in october and about
whether biden should sit down
with the min online um i think we can
talk about both of those together as you
know alternative strategies
um
that may or may not be combined with
what's happening internal to myanmar and
it's and it's armed resistance in some
sense but what are some of the other
possible negotiating strategies or forms
of pressure that might be put on to the
junta
maybe scott i'll ask you to start that
conversation but again not leave it all
on your shoulders
um thanks i appreciate that eric um
again i i certainly can't speak for the
us government on on this on on
you know the session
on the attending the aussie
meetings um
but i can say
in previous discussions internal u.s
governments uh discussions that i was a
part of you know some years ago
on sanctions the the approach generally
was to look at you know what's the
impact of the sanctions in this case the
goal
is clear which is to squeeze the junta's
finances i mean the biden administration
has made that clear through the actions
it's already taken
the other side of that is what are the
negative consequences
of any sanctions
and so you know in some cases you get
you know if you get very broad sanctions
you could be harming a lot of other
people
so i would guess in the context of
looking at potential mogee sanctions
again it's a
what are the positives i.e reducing
revenue to the regime to the junta
versus whatever costs or downsides there
are of that and i'm not i'm not privy to
those conversations so i don't know
um
how that's going in terms of the
president's potential participation in
the asean meetings i think it's really
important i don't know what the white
house is thinking or what it will do of
course i think that's important this is
not just a myanmar right this is all of
southeast asia uh 10 countries 600
million people so
the president's participation in those
meetings is really important uh because
of an entire region that's that's quite
uh in many
ways um and where um i think there's a
strong demand for uh in the region for
us participation
obviously uh it wouldn't be any
president's first choice to sit down at
a meeting that includes men online
um i i don't but i think it's it
whatever that if the president does
decide to participate
i think it's important not to take that
as oh he's okay with the hunter clearly
we're not oh the united states is not
okay with the junta but it is important
to look at it in the context of the
overall relationship with all of
southeast asia not just in the myanmar
context
i'd be interested to hear from the other
panelists
about the symbolic meaning of
if biden were to sit down at the table
how would that be received
among
me and people in myanmar
members of the nug and other
affiliated groups interested in the
myanmar situation right now
out of curiosity maybe we could start
with matida
well i think the
uh first of all i think the
international community should accept
the failure of the five wine census
uh regarding the oxygen intervention i
think they did if we cannot recognize
this we will end up in the trap of asean
all the time even though we are the part
of asean asean
every single countries of the asean
cannot guarantee any democracy because
they are still struggling by themselves
so for that reason i think the
even though the u.s intervention is just
uh through the platform of the uni uh uh
or the by itself uh to encourage more
intervention through aseans with no walk
but at the same time uh i think the
uh
i i hope i seriously do whole but
it's
not very promising the current the
unassembly
people the the other countries should
also seriously think about their role
for the intervention not just u.s
because
uh somehow for example like the still we
still do need to
take account for the intervention from
the uh china and russia because the
people-to-people
relationship through
among the
myanmar and china is very very
uh obvious so my concern is there are a
couple of uh diplomatic relationship
it's sometimes it's purely the gdg
and this kind of things cannot work
properly because the g2g pressure will
only affect on the sac the terminal
because it's turned out to be like the
current government
but what we do need is more intervention
through the other platform p2p people to
people through the civil society
organization through the academic
institution so and so so in that case
asean is also another big challenge you
know because the most of the asean
countries turn out to be the refuge
area for
the military families members too so in
that case i think the
the pressure from the other countries
including us towards the asean countries
is not to
become part of the refuge
palace for the military officers in
terms of the legal immigration status or
the uh
other other way economic uh investment
something like that so we
should think about some other ways to
make the uh do
pressure on the rtn itself so first of
all we need to acknowledge the failure
of the five wine sensors it's already
gone for my eyes so we should think
about the new uh strategy and the
solution not just through only us here
then we should build up the the
more
cooperative and collective solutions
through
more countries not just asia
thank you uh cartoon did you want to add
to this
i i could uh if if i
um i'm wrong um i think the
the inter the
matthew what matthew said is a very
eloquent in terms of how useful rcn
would be for the united states if by the
administration want to sort of create
another platform we need to really
reconsider not based on that five point
and diplomatic attempt they started out
but it has to be a different format but
from the point of view of the people
inside burma cdm participant the
protesters themselves and citizens
themselves they have no really
big hope in terms of international
intervention they understand it but the
only thing that they want is the
indonesian community support national
unity government which is the elected
government of burma november 8 2020
elected government of burma or myanmar
and that government should be
for international community easy to
support uh the u.n is now underway with
the unga
uh uh it is recently just yesterday it's
a schedule that ambassador ujo morton
were about to speak uh gave a speech on
september 27 was put side to side to set
aside because the credential committee
uh uh is dealing with sensitive
political issue within the commodity on
the burma question so i mean it is
really a shame for the un not to be able
to bravely support the elected
government of burma and so
and and and also the the united nations
security council should at least now
begin to table substantive discussion
and maybe have taken action on the
economic uh and arms umber goal
especially arms umbergo against the
military regime so these framework could
be discussed if i didn't want to sort of
uh
create a new framework with rcm that's
the first thing the united states have
to state is a baseline the baseline is
us ambassador sir martial have already
indicated that current military
leadership may not lie and the top sac
member has to be cited set aside they
need to step out of it a new generation
of military leader if the i don't want
to sort of create that framework if
asean want to create that thing what
but it is really for the for the myanmar
public it is impossible to accept even
to that level due to what madida had
eloquently stated about the level of
trust to this institution so i think
we are dealing with the traditional
state-centric politic that the world is
used to and here a pretty uh important
politic that is uh sort of defined by
the public in burma uh never been before
in the world that we are seeing such a
skill of resilient robust uh population
that is against their own state and so
that this question was never posed on
the world uh institution since the
founding of the united nations in 1945
the united nations need to rethink in
that rethinking process we need to
request consider those kind of state
sovereignty all of the r2p and then just
war intervention i mean chapter six and
seven are laid out for a reason we know
that you're in charter chapter six and
seven so these are all kind of elements
uh to rethink for the international
diplomatic community
and also united states department this
as a global affair that's moving forward
with some sort of element that asean
leader might maybe listen but hopeless
asean is a very hopeless institution
because
malaysia
singapore and indonesia are three
respectable countries in terms of the
freedom of individuals i mean the human
rights violation and all that so right
other than that they are not much so
that would be my
two cents
um
we have a couple more minutes left uh
we're planning to end at 1 15. we can go
for a few minutes beyond that but um
there's two questions
uh
that are a little bit more specific but
one of them builds from the u.n
discussion that we were just talking
about representation in the u.n um and
there's another aspect of representation
about the refugees in mizoram that's
raised by zoma
and i wondered if you could speak to
that but maybe think a little bit more
broadly about the representation issue
and
um people who are leaving myanmar for
various purposes and what can be done to
support them
and then um there's another question
after that that i hope we can turn to
about speculations on the military um
logistics of the actual opposition
groups do they have a chance um and so
i'd like to talk to that and i think we
may run out of time at that point but
we'll see where we get
david you haven't spoken uh since the
last time do do you want to start this
one
about representation of refugees perhaps
um
i mean um
india is slightly different from yama of
course they have uh uh the
the federal rule like for example many
chin people fled to uh mizoram and
miuram have their own way of
making the decisions to welcome them
that that's good news and i would like
to express some of the young people to
join this panel thank you all for
welcoming those especially chin and
catching people or for welcoming them in
your in your home state
uh
i really don't know since this has
more to do with this the u.n
recognitions of the refugees i really
don't know whether i might
have some insight perhaps i think scott
muscle might have more insights about
that
go ahead scott if you'd like to jump in
um okay uh i'm i'm certainly not an
expert on this issue but i i'd like to
say two things first i'm on the un i
know we all we tend to think of the u.n
as some kind of
independent or institution and it and it
is in a way i mean you have the
secretary general and his staff
but fundamentally um so you have um
organizations
uh that work directly for the secretary
general for example managing the refugee
issue and so on but when the u.n when
you talk about the general assembly or
the security council it's a collection
of countries
it's not that you when the um security
council or general assembly fails to do
something it's not the u.n per se it's
because a block of countries says no
um and it's important to to to keep that
in mind
on the refugee issue uh i mean um
generally the the u.n high commission
for refugees high commissioner for
refugees and his agency will uh seek
access to people who are who have fled
uh who are seeking asylum um it depends
on the host country's willingness to let
the u.n interview them and then the u.n
would interview them u.n experts would
interview them and determine whether
they have
uh whether they qualify for refugee
status so that's it's it's really you
know it
to say it sounds a technical issue
sounds so impersonal but it's
the undis individual decisions on those
refugees are you know based on certain
criteria but the key is for the un uh
for refugees
to be granted access by whichever
country is hosting in this case it would
be thailand and india um and so that's
that's really where that stands and and
i don't know the
what discussions are going on between
the u.n and the government of india and
the government of thailand i'm sure
there are lots of discussions happening
but i'm just not privy to them
well as far as i know
the situation of the refugee status
waiting in the either in india or
thailand is more or less directly
related to the recognition of the nug
you know so they having us a lot of
people who looking for the refugee
status they having asked whether they
support the nug statement on the
september 7th and the interpretation of
these statements
from some agency is more or less like
supporting
violence but
as far as i understand the statements by
nug on the september 7th is
uh saying the state of emergency that's
all this is the state of emergency but
some of the domestic and international
media also interpret that
as the the d-day for the armed
revolution something like that that's
why some of the international agency
interpreted
and then they asked the refugee
applicant saying that if you support the
statements for nug on the 7th september
are you supporting violence something
like that so i think this is the whole
ideological conflict and understanding
about the struggle of our revolution by
the uh international community this is
very pretty much very important and
pretty much impactful that's why
please count it
the interpretation and
the
reflecting on the media not as as it's
the original document set so be
more uh
try to dig enough what's really going on
and what's the meaning of the statements
and the status of the nug should be
recognized
not by
this statement
that's that's my thought
thank you um we we just have uh
two or three more minutes
and i i'd like to end although it may be
um
a sobering way to end the conversation
but there is this question um from
um
about the pdf's relative inexperience in
military logistics
um
and this concern about its ability to
prevail over the top
i would be interested in hearing this
after we speak about this uh what i will
do is then
um stop the recording and we can have an
open conversation for those who wish to
stick around for another 10 minutes
after that but maybe we can make this
the final formal response to panel
discussion
um
and
um
maybe uh kotoon you could you could
start uh with your response
wow um
the
unhcr question i would like to connect
to uh to this uh respond to this
question uh
if unhcr
if they can function within eaos
uh and working with eaos if they cannot
stand their own personals uh this is the
time to actually to be brave and bold if
they want to really help the situation
inside internally displaced people
as david already said the the city in uh
chin state has only 28
residents left where did they go how do
we help them right
of course to the india and then other
area within myanmar as well so with that
um um
also the pd
the question now how do we um
i i'm i can you rephrase a little bit
that question i did not read that
question eric uh if you if you don't
mind
um yeah the question is basically um
does the for the opposition group
have a chance of prevailing over the
tatmudo
it's a kind of military question in a
sense to say if it turns to full violent
resistance
um what are the chances of winning
thank you um i think the
the conventional war uh uh they are well
prepared the military is well prepared
and what the pdf and others are
imagining uh the sort of a war of
attrition type attrition wall uh which
is although what the
broader sense of international economic
sanctions and so on uh try to sort of
chip up with the the power of the
existing authoritarian thai government
these are sort of in line with that kind
of thinking
um i think if they engage in such kind
of war
and at the same time if they engage with
some of the uh low-level soldiers within
the military uh sort of conversation
with them and what the
cnnf and ug has been recently offering
them some sort of reward financial and
safety for them if they want to join the
public and in a peaceful cdm way if they
can empty out which is also the
intention of cdm movement uh the the
civil servants who wanted to [ __ ] the
function of the military council and who
want to actually don't see that military
council's government properly working
as a authoritarian government so cdm has
a dead intention and so
they kind of sort of work with pdf and
the nug can work with which they are
already beginning to uh if that
combined with what pdf are doing
i think it is a jazz wall it is just if
you are taking down the airplanes and
trucks and
mitel tower which will be used by the
military to kill its own people i mean
they are not attacking uh people
civilian all the military men here
they're just basically taking away uh
like kachin kia has started way back in
the gasoline truck coming from china
destroying them on the road uh letting
the driver flee all kinds of these kind
of peaceful action that they're doing uh
type of war but attrition if you will
and that kind of war and strategy well
coordinated will be i think quite useful
for uh making the military especially
low-level soldier all the way to maybe
that reaching a commander level to join
the cdm and then empty out the military
institution at the top uh who will not
change their mind at this point and they
they have so much stake in their
families like material are saying their
their future their businesses and so on
if nug mpdf can orchestrate that
uh and with ea was what they were doing
so what i'm saying is a broader
type of
activity
is needed to really win this uh this
wall and that of course need to be
detailed out so for instance military
soldiers who are ordered to shoot on the
street they can point it in the round
direction and instead of shooting people
they can
shoot it to other people and so that
kind of military man's sort of their own
internal resistance against their own
leader's order making sure their trucks
are sort of the wire is not wiping the
battery is not charged and the gasoline
is not uh enough to arrive from point a
to point b military man if they want to
join cdm in such a way from inside
without taking of uniform and they can
do so and that these kind of mechanism
can be implemented with the coordination
of nug pdf strategies and communication
with these potential cdm uh
thinking military men so if that kind of
war if that kind of strategy can be
structured i think there's a chance of
winning
if you are going out to conventional war
who know
a flight from china with military men on
the side might come that's a i mean very
sobering international relations
security kind of imagination i'm
thinking here it would have i don't i
don't mean to say it could happen it
will happen but it is possibility there
right so all out all the way to the
support from china and possibly russian
military and maybe some israeli
communication equipment that are making
money out of this kind of a crisis in
the world for a long time these kind of
thing had to be really orchestrated in
thinking process and structuring the the
world that nug might be intentionally
intending to do i do not know exactly
what they are thinking that would be
where i i would uh leave
thank you um if anyone has a short final
comment i'd love to hear that and then
i'll bring it to close and then we'll
have an informal discussion afterwards
any final comments
well i think the former intention of the
this armed resistance is
you know as the military have
only the language of weapons they have
no other language for that reasons the
the revolutions
groups decided to make sure the
military started listening to them with
this armed struggle and then the final
decision will be on the table by the
bologna leaders that's that's the real
intention of the
uh from the very very beginning for the
armed revolution i think
okay well thank you everyone for this
fascinating conversation it's really the
beginning of what i think will be a long
series of conversations about these
complex issues um but i most importantly
i want to thank you all for joining us
um and uh please everyone in attendance
join me in thanking the panelists thank
you very much